the diamond princess is the single
largest cluster of coronavirus outside
China with more than 300 confirmed cases
its passengers and crew have been
quarantined on this floating isolation
unit but for some US citizens at least
that ordeal came to an end this evening
from the services this message is for
all our American customers disembarking
the diamond princess today
we have just received a final
confirmation from u.s. embassy that the
new luggage collection time is going to
be 7:00 p.m. this evening okay even
better the knowledge that they were on
their way out to home and to safety all
right let me flip it around here or can
I 13 buses they have their curtains
drawn we're gonna go to Travis Air Force
Base yeah in California for Laughlin's
Air Force Base in Texas
but many are left behind kept to their
confinement including British nationals
there is no UK evacuation currently
scheduled every country except the UK
has become involved and that is really
wonderful for the people onboard the
ship every country except for the United
Kingdom can I just tell you UK how this
makes me really feel it feels that we
have been forgotten that you don't
really care about us and that you're
actually not wanting us to come home a
Foreign Office spokesperson said we are
urgently speaking to authorities in
Japan and the UK we're working around
the clock to ensure the welfare of the
British nationals on board a serious is
the situation on board the diamond
princesses there are only a few hundred
cases in China there are now more than
68,000 the vast majority here in Hubei
province and there are more questions
about the Chinese authorities management
of the epidemic
it's emerged that President Xi Jingping
chaired a meeting on how to deal with
the crisis back on the 7th of January
long before the rest of the world and
the Chinese public even knew there was a
crisis coming but there was also perhaps
some hope today or to the third
consecutive drop in the number of new
cases reported it's too early to know
what that means for the trajectory of
the disease and certainly for those on
the front line overwhelmed and exhausted
there is no respite yet
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing